all right listen let's quit [ __ ]
around let's do a song that's what we're
here to do right right let's get
everybody excited Imagine Dragons Ronnie
just Ronnie's 73 year old Ronnie who
works for me just went to your concert
you're turning him on I mean you boys
attract people across the board shout
out to Ronnie yes
[Music]
first things first time I say all the
words inside my head I'm fired up and
tired of the way that things have been
over
the way that things have been old
now second day second don't you tell me
what you think that I should be I'm the
one at the sale I'm the master of my CEO
[Music]
seeing the beauty through the
hey you made me yeah you made me a
Believer believer
[Music]
believers
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
see I was choking in the crowd building
my brain up in the clouds falling like
Ashes to the ground over my feelings
they would drowned they never did ever
lived up and I'm throwing inhibit the
limited till it broke open the rain down
it rained down
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
rain
okay
[Music]
[Music]
come on
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
break me down you build me a believer
believe
it
[Music]
Bravo boys nice that is a beautiful
arrangement of that song the harmonies
take me in a room you're about to
rehearse that show me what you guys do
we all find a different first note we
all sort of know the way it's supposed
to go sort of intuitively what are you
singing under there when Dan's doing the
lead what are you sing it well actually
in this song I'm doing a hybrid you may
be uh you made me a believer
believer Dan what do you do you go high
you made me you made me a believer
really kind of an octave up and then
wait an hour down low maybe uh you made
me a believer
believer and then bring it all together
now please without anything
[Music]
thank you